have we seen mobius's pizza station  wagon before  not in the mcu but it is a great nod to  the disney pixar pizza planet truck  is frog thor our new favorite thor chris  hemsworth himself is the one who made  all the noises coming from throgg  why is it that all these people in the  mcu wake up covered in sand  this is a big throwback to the very  first iron man film  is yellowjacket missing his abnormally  large helmet  it's found in the void in loki as well  the thanos copter has returned to the  loki series  there was also a nod to the famous  copter and wandavision  ronin the accuser's ship has been found  the dark aster appears to be crashed in  the field in loki